>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Anne E. McLean: Good
evening, I'm Anne McLean
from the Library's Concert Office.
We're presenting tonight a
wonderfully rich evening of music
by Czech composers, Antonin
Dvorak and Bohuslav Martinu
from the excellent
Pavel Haas Quartet.
It's very unusual to have on offer
in one concert both the Dvorak
American Quartet Opus 96
and also the D Minor
Quartet Opus 34.
And we are especially pleased to
be able to preface this concert
with this lecture by Michael
Beckerman who's an authority
on Czech composers and
Eastern European music,
among other subjects.
Dr. Beckman was awarded the
prestigious [inaudible] medal
from the Czech Republic and he is a
laureate of the Czech Music Council.
It's a pleasure really for us to
welcome him back to the library.
He is the Carroll and Milton
Petrie professor of music
at New York University and the
author of benchmark studies
on these composers we'll
be hearing tonight,
including one fascinating book
called New Worlds of Dvorak,
Searching in America for
the Composer's Inner Life.
And that book we have available
for sale in our anteroom tonight.
He's also the editor of
Dvorak and His World.
So let me just say also
that I wanted to mention
if you're really interested in these
subjects, please check out a lecture
by Dr. Beckman that
is now already online
on our website Dvorak
in the New World.
He lectured here a few years ago and
this is on our website www.LOC.gov
and this lecture examines the
role of African-American sources
in the conception of
an American music.
So please help me welcome
Michael Beckman.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Beckerman: Thank you,
thank you for the love introduction,
I'm delighted to be back
here at the library.
Well I thought I would begin
by mentioning two composers
who actually aren't on the program.
I'll begin by playing one.
[ Music ]
This piece, which sounds like late
Beethoven was actually written
by a contemporary of
Mozart's named Jakub Jan Ryba.
Famous for writing one of
the most popular pieces
in the Czech lands
called the Christmas Mass.
But this [inaudible] quartet was
written long before Beethoven
and I play it to remind us all
that there is really a long
and distinguished tradition of Czech
string quartet writing or better
yet a string quartet writing in
what are known as the Czech lands.
Composers like [inaudible],
the Stamitzs, many others,
Wranitzkys who are contemporaries
of Mozart wrote wonderful quartets.
Certainly Smetana in his
contemporaries then Dvorak.
The followers of Dvorak Josef
Suk, [inaudible], Novak, Martinu.
There's just a long and
distinguished tradition
of these composers working in this
medium and it's probably pushing it
to say that somehow this medium is
specifically suited to the Czechs.
But there are things about it I
think which points that can be made
and I'll try to make
them as I go along.
The second composer I'm going to
mention and it would be obvious why,
his works are not being
played, but is Pavel Haas.
Pavel Haas was a wonderful composer,
a student of Janacek's who was
in Terezin where he wrote several
wonderful pieces and was killed
in Auschwitz in in the in 1945.
But he was again an
extraordinary figure
and a wonderful quartet
composer, a student of Janacek's
who both carried on that particular
Moravian tradition or sub tradition
of Czech string quartets, but also
went very much in his own direction.
But we're going to begin
tonight with someone
from another generation,
certainly not of the Dvorak,
Smetana generation this
is Bohuslav Martinu.
Martinu famously born in a church
tower very high above the small town
of Policka where his father
was a professional fire water
because he was also a shoemaker,
but you needed more
than one job in Policka.
And there are a hundred
steps above the church
where the Martinu family
lived in a small room.
And he came down from the tower
really only at about the age of 10,
went to Prague studied there.
It was a student after my own
heart because he was thrown
out of school several times
for incorrigible laziness.
And he decided to go to Paris and
I'll get to why he decided to go
to Paris in a moment,
but I thought I'd begin
by playing just the opening
of this third string quartet
which was written in Paris in 1939.
[ Music ]
Well anyone who actually is familiar
with Martinu would probably be right
to say this is quite on the
dissonant edge of Martinu's writing.
Martinu again is in Paris
in 1929, he's in the thrall
of many different composers,
very interested in French notions
of clarity, but also very much
in the thrall of Stravinsky
as one can hear by
these motoric rhythms.
But there is one way in which
Martinu's works tend to differ
from those of Stravinsky
and many others.
And you can hear it in the next
passage because what happens
when this motoric style
slows down a bit.
[ Music ]
So you get, you know, you
get all this I don't know,
you know, Martinu.
[ Music ]
So you get one of these sort
of little syncopated passages
that at various times quite
specifically seem to refer
to his notion of something Czech.
But really become part of his
style and this is another I think
of Martinu who wrote -- by the
time he wrote this it's 1929,
he was born in 1890 he's not that
old he's already written 200 pieces.
Martinu is among the most prolific
composers of the 20th century.
He wrote, you know, well I once a
wrote an article called How Many
Pieces did Martinu Write because
depending on how you choose
to measure pieces you get
any number from 350 to 600.
You know, is it three
etudes, three pieces
or is it one piece called three
etude, you know, things like that.
But he wrote a lot of music and
a lot of extraordinary music.
And this aspect of his style
is something you can hear even
in a quite dissonant piece.
I'll give you a couple of examples
from maybe more famous pieces of his
of how these sort of almost
insect-like textures sort
of give way to this sort of
syncopated sort of Martinu sound.
And in that way again, he
strikes me as very much
like a painter who
has his own style.
I mean not all Jackson
Pollocks are alike,
but they're all Jackson Pollocks.
And Martinu has certain
musical fingerprints.
So this is from the sixth
Symphony much later.
[ Music ]
So you get these kinds of
sounds and you'll hear that even
in this quartet as he
goes kind of in and out
of these highly dissonant textures,
which open up into
these little windows.
And like a lot of pieces this
quartet ends with a kind of,
I mean a movement ends
with a kind of fanfare.
[ Music ]
Sorry, the second movement of
this quartet is very much a kind
of inward turning lyrical piece
with a lot of viola solos.
[ Music ]
And it's quite again an
extraordinary movement
that has a much more
consonant center.
The last movement begins like
the first, a kind of really harsh
and sharp dissonant texture.
[ Music ]
And again, in the middle
of the movement we get one
of these little Martinu
windows opening up.
[ Music ]
Now this is a Martinu
piece unlike some of them
where there's more dissonance
than you usually get
in one of his pieces.
And it's tricky for a
long time I thought that
and maybe this was just sort of
self-serving that the piece was
about the consonances and that that
he wasn't as invested aesthetically
in the dissonances
as he was in those --
that those moments were
the real Martinu moments,
but I think that was wrong.
I think they're all Martinu moments
and it's I think an exciting kind
of aesthetic experience when you
have again, this level of dissonance
which is opening up and I'll
make a kind of trite suggestion
that I can't sort of stay away from.
But Martinu did have this very
strange experience of growing
up in this tower and he wrote
about it quite a bit and, you know,
he said I was in the
tower all the time
and in the tower I could always
see these absolutely still
natural forms.
I could see the fields and
the shapes of the fields
and the people weren't
really people they were
like little ants or something.
And part of me thinks that
this tendency of Martinu is
to always do this, to always
open out into this sort
of still moment even in
the most dissonant pieces.
You know, is a part of
him that might be related
to that very special
circumstance in which he grew up,
you can take that or leave it.
But, you know, I can't discount it
because I think it was
important enough to him.
So we're going to hear two
string quartets by Dvorak.
One of the things I thought
of titling this talk was well
if we call Dvorak's Opus 96 the
American quartet what should we call
the other quartets?
Should we call Martinu's the
Parisian, the Parisian Tower.
And what do we call Dvorak's
non-American quartet,
do we call it a Czech quartet or?
So let's just begin by
listening to the opening
of the first movement here.
[ Music ]
So there would seem to be to me
absolutely nothing national in it,
no spices, no paprika
to make Hungarian chicken
or American spices.
And it uses a kind of standard.
[ Music ]
So to go back and forth
between major and minor,
but that's something
that Schubert does.
This seems to be very
much within the larger,
particularly German quartet
tradition of the composers
that Dvorak loved and Mozart
and Haydn, especially Schubert.
Mozart, I mean Dvorak was quite
reticent, he wasn't a literary man.
But one of the only articles
he wrote was about Schubert,
so he was very much a
Schubertian, Schumann.
Certainly Brahms, it's
well-known that these --
the quartet was dedicated to Brahms.
And Brahms of course, clucked a bit
and said, well young man, you know,
I like this piece okay, but you
really need to be a bit more careful
around the edges and they had that
kind of relationship that it's,
you know, I don't know what
it says about Brahms to say
that Dvorak might have
been his favorite composer,
but he would still
wag his finger at him.
But they had an extraordinary
relationship and I think he wanted
to write -- Dvorak very much
wanted to write a quartet
that fit into that tradition.
Now the quartet is not without
sort of obligatory genuflections
to the worlds of nation
and nationality.
You know, the second movement
is a polka or ala polka.
[ Music ]
So this is just at the moment
where Dvorak is figuring himself
out about how he's going to
bill himself, how he's going
to portray himself, particularly
in the German-speaking lands.
This is almost like a little bit
of one of his Slavonic dances
that sort of intrudes into this.
But you know you also get
one of the wonderful moments
in this quartet is the trio,
the middle section of this polka
where everything stops
and you get a little kind
of Christmas pastoral absolutely
exquisite sort of rural moment.
[ Music ]
So there's a bit of a clash and
a wonderful one in this piece
between this sort of darker D
minor opening movement of polka
and then the polka
opening up into sort
of a little almost
Beethovenian image of this kind
of rural bliss that's just really,
you know, an extraordinary thing
and I think it's something
that Brahms noticed as well.
You can hear Dvorak's debts
to some of his predecessors,
particularly in the last movement.
Oops sorry.
That's the lea, I skipped the second
movement and that's my favorite one.
So let me talk about the second
movement, I mean the slow movement.
The slow movement, the
adagio is again one
of Dvorak's great movements.
It's absolutely I think devoid
of any kind of nationalizing,
any sort of genuflections
in those directions.
And it pursues a formal structure
that many composers employed,
but Dvorak I think to particular
effect, which is begins as a kind
of romance, as a highly
expressive romance and then
as the movement goes on it simply
gets more and more expressive
until the very middle of the piece
where it kind -- where it explodes.
But here's the opening of it.
[ Music ]
So setting this tone
of kind of reflection,
prayerfulness, but also romance.
So there are kind of two middles
as it gets more and more intense.
The first one almost suggests a
kind of Spanish harmonic quality.
[ Music ]
So this is also this
is a kind of reference
to something quite exotic
Dvorak loved to do that.
Here's a kind of similar passage
from his famous violin romance.
[ Music ]
So not very Czech right.
I mean so there's a lot of
languages that Dvorak is pulling on.
There's Brahms in the high style,
there's Czechness [phonetic]
when he needs a polka and
there's Spanish style,
little pastoral style
taken from early Beethoven.
But in the middle of this
piece and some of you
who have heard me might know
that I'm a great, great believer
in middles that, I mean
if you actually push me
to the wall I'd say the only
purpose of outer movements is
so that there can be a middle.
And that all the best
stuff happens in the middle
and if it's not in
the middle of moving.
And here again, just to remind
you this is the opening [music].
So this is the opening
of the slow movement.
[ Music ]
That gesture and when it comes
back in the real absolute center
of the piece it sounds like this.
[ Music ]
So you have the whole show
you've got the violins
and octaves playing
at parallel intervals.
You've got the pizzicato, you've
got the tremolos, you know,
every single sort of musical
sign of excess romance
of over the topness [phonetic].
And I think there are no other
composers who really do this
at that time, it's really
quite and you could hear it
in many other pieces by Dvorak.
The slow movement the seventh
symphony, some of the piano trio
and the piano quartet all have these
and so I think it's a real treat.
I hope you look forward to it.
You can actually stop the quartet
in the middle after that passage
and ask them to play it, no, no.
Okay and here's the
last movement of it.
[ Music ]
Okay, so that opening
and then followed by.
[ Music ]
Okay, so the opening itself,
you know, is kind of reminiscent
of another quartet, a
favorite of Dvorak's,
the quartet Death of
the Maiden [music].
So here's Dvorak.
[ Music ]
But also reminds us a
little bit of the rhythms
of the Schubert quintet in C.
[ Music ]
But again, listen after the
opening what happens right.
So this is the [inaudible].
[ Music ]
A little a few, a little
contrapuntal passage,
which I think was stolen from
let's see if I can get it right,
happily stolen from, you know,
I mean he gives it
back, but it is here.
So okay.
[ Music ]
So it's this, you know
the trio from the scherzo
from the Beethoven fifth.
So he's taken that from Schubert
and he's taken that from Beethoven,
but the amazing thing is he's
put them together, you know,
he's put them together one
right next to the other
and it creates a really
powerful effect.
So, you know, this is quite an
astonishing piece this quartet
with enormous power.
Dvorak was a young man when he
wrote it and it really is one
of his great early works.
So I'm back here at this podium
where I was some years ago trying
to talk about Dvorak's
American works.
What it means that a composer who
thought of himself as Czech got
on a boat, landed in
New York and decided
that he would try to
write American music.
It was an astonishing thing,
it's still an astonishing thing.
And the F Major Quartet is
one of the greatest products.
So first let me go over quickly
some of you may know it the story
of Dvorak and the United States.
He was brought to the United States
by an extraordinary woman
named Jeanette Thurber.
Jeanette Thurber was a
brilliant woman who decided
that the United States should
try to hold its own with Europe
in terms of musical culture.
She started an opera company,
she believed in opera in English.
She had the for its
time or maybe honestly
for any time the astonishing
idea that anybody should be able
to study music regardless of
their background, their color,
their economic level, their
religion, their gender.
She wanted to create an institution
that would be open to all.
And she fastened on Dvorak
because she knew that Dvorak came
from humble circumstances
and thought
that he would make
a marvelous leader
for her national conservatory,
which she started
on East 17th Street now the site
of Washington Irving High School,
but formerly the site of
the National Conservatory.
She paid Dvorak what we already know
was a princely wage in 1893, 92,
93 to come to the United
States and the reasons
that she wanted Dvorak
were I think threefold.
The first again, she wanted
to create an institution
in the United States that
would be of such high quality
that students would not feel
the need to go to Europe
to finish their musical education.
So she thought well let's get
the best people in the world,
let's use American know-how and
especially money to hire some
of the best people so that
people didn't have to go abroad.
The second as I've
already mentioned,
she wanted to have an
institution which she felt was true
to the principles of this country,
of the ideals of this country
that would be open to everybody.
And if people couldn't pay their
tuition would be paid it didn't
matter what their background was.
So she had many women students,
African-American students,
students from all kinds
of backgrounds.
But the third thing she wanted and
this is really where Dvorak came
in whether it's a wrongheaded
idea from the get-go
or not is something you
all can decide over time,
I think there are many perspectives.
But she wanted a music that would
sound American the way she thought
Russian music was Russian,
Hungarian music was Hungarian
and Czech music was Czech.
She wanted something that would be
an equivalent and she brought it --
you can view it as an
experiment that she's a scientist
and she brought Dvorak
over as an experiment.
By the way, I'm just
reminded as I'm speaking one
of the great science-fiction stories
I read was by is called a Work
of Art by James Bliss, it's
online you can read it.
And hundreds of years or
maybe a thousand years
in the future I can't quite remember
they recreate Ricard Strauss
out of some scientific principle so
that he can write works for them,
but he can't because
he's out of his time.
But this is kind of an experiment
she's bringing Dvorak to America,
she's saying okay, I'm going
to give you all kinds of queues
and let's see what it means
to write American music.
So Dvorak arrives in the
United States October 1892.
If you do your math October
12, 1892 is not the 500th,
but the 400th anniversary
of Columbus.
There are many talks about
the new world of music,
a title that gets picked up by
Dvorak later for a work that some
of you may know, the
New World Symphony.
And additionally, he
hears that first week
because his hotel is right over one
of the main parade routes all sort
of the music of America,
blacksmiths choirs, you know,
spirituals are marching
under his window.
Not only that, he's famous, he's
incredibly famous and as you know,
all of you I'm sure
who are all famous
that when you're famous
people give you things.
People just come up to you
and they give you things
and so everyone is
giving Dvorak music
and they're saying look
at this music right.
And one of the real preoccupations
of Jeanette Thurber was the idea
that Dvorak should fuse the
local styles of the United States
to create something Czech.
And that meant to her mind not only
the various styles of Celtic music
or French music, but primarily
in her view African-American
and Native American.
Dvorak very quickly seems to fall
in love with African-American song.
There are I think many
reasons for it.
Reason one, he was hearing
some extraordinary music
that he never heard before.
Another thing was Dvorak was deeply
religious and as you may know,
Czech folksongs generally are about
drinking wine and chasing girls.
And suddenly he found what he
thought was an American folk music,
which was biblical.
It was all about Daniel in the
lion's den and go down Moses.
He very quickly hooked up with
Harry T. Burley, who was studying
at the school and also working there
who is an extraordinary singer,
whose grandfather had been a slave.
And as Burley walked with
his grandfather in Erie,
Pennsylvania his grandfather
became a lamplighter.
The grandfather sang all
these songs for Burley and so
to Dvorak Burley seemed
like an authentic source
for what this music was.
Dvorak also was in with a group
of people who felt that because
of the history of slavery
it wasn't only
that African-American music was
expressive or very expressive
that it was the most expressive.
That it was the music that
should be the foundation
for an American style.
And Dvorak in a long interview
with a yellow journalist named
James Creelman, whose signature,
he signed that over at the picture,
was signed over to Creelman.
To my dear friend, James Creelman.
That he said in this
article the future
of American music should
be based on black music.
He had found this also
in an article written
by a wonderful woman named
Mildred Hill, who wrote an article
under the pseudonym Johann
Tonsor called Negro Music
and argued the same
thing that the future
of American music should be black.
That this is where
the source should be.
And Dvorak took this
very much to heart.
The New World Symphony is steeped in
these, you know, these [music] and,
you know, swing-low and Dvorak cuts
out the first measure and sorry,
it's too small a keyboard.
I have to sing the top.
So we have this sort of reliance
on black melody, certain levels
of expression that were
really new to Dvorak.
So Dvorak writes the
New World Symphony
in the winter and the
spring of 1893.
In May of 1893, he gives this
interview with New York Herald
where he basically says
American music should be based
on black models.
And there's a huge
controversy around it,
people argue some agree,
some disagree.
Can this really be the
source for American music?
Dvorak wants to get
away from it all,
so it ends up going out
to Spillville, Iowa.
Now Spillville, Iowa
was a Czech colony,
it goes back to the 1830's and 40's.
He went there because his secretary
who was an American-born Czech named
Josef [inaudible] his family lived
there and suddenly after all this
very stressful time writing the
symphony, getting involved in
this controversy he finds himself
in nature, he finds himself
in the middle of Iowa
and where everybody actually
-- all the people there,
you know, came over in the 1840's.
So they all talked like his
grandparents even though they're
his age.
So he sits around with these farmers
and he drinks beer and he feels
like he's at home again and he
snaps his fingers and writes two
of the greatest works in the
Chamber of music Repertoire.
The first, the American
quartet was written in a flash,
it was written in less
than two weeks.
And I think it's an
extraordinary work in many ways.
First of all, it's Dvorak
again in his American-style,
here's the famous opening
of the quartet.
[ Music ]
So this kind of.
Sort of, you know, huge spaces,
that's another aspect
of the American style.
So-called five note scales right.
[ Music ]
But also the space of it.
So you have a sense of Dvorak's
sense of openness and space.
It's not that different from, sorry.
[ Music ]
The new world symphony's
[inaudible], this is.
So it had that sense
of expansiveness, of
energy, of reaching.
Okay, since I threw a
little autobiographical
in talking about Martinu.
I think that there is a kind
of slight autobiographical
tinge to this.
I think this work almost
hinges sometimes on the manic
and I think Dvorak was so
extraordinarily excited to get back,
to get into nature, to be himself
again after being in the city
that this opening sound of
Dvorak was famously a violist.
[ Music ]
I think that's sort I'm back,
not literally, but you know,
just so that you know this is a
guy who wrote a piece called Song
of the Hero, which was
an autobiographical work.
He wrote other kind of
autobiographical things.
There's a very long-standing
tradition, well not that long,
but [inaudible] his famous quartet
was autobiographical from my life.
And I think this is a kind of
Dvorak has put himself into it much
in the same way I think he puts
himself as a kind of character
into that other great bookend
work of the American years
that is the cello concerto.
Well perhaps the most
extraordinary movement
in this quartet is
the slow movement,
is the middle movement again.
I think Dvorak did find
this whole beautiful part
of Iowa extraordinary, but one
thing he kept saying, he kept saying
that sometimes he says, you
know, it's so wild here,
it's so wild that this is said
unto despair, it's like a desert.
And I think that's
something he tried
to capture in the second movement.
[ Music ]
So this is really an extraordinary.
You know, these kinds of harmonies
where and Dvorak love those sort
of nothing really happens, it's not
as if you have a sense
of harmonic movement.
It's as if the lights
shifted a little bit.
And so you get this and this
is written I think in the --
at least partially in
this Schubertian sort
of heavenly length traditionally.
It just really goes on and
on, there's no real pause.
It just keeps unfolding
and intensifying
in a way that's really
quite marvelous.
It has the quality of lament to it
and several times people
have referred to it
as a kind of Indian lament.
And that's one of the chapters of
Dvorak's time in the United States,
which is most poorly understood
and I don't know if we ever will.
Well when Dvorak's
first great biographer
in English John Clapham
wrote about Dvorak's time
in Iowa he became puzzled
because there was a reference
to the Kickapoo and he wanted to
know what tribe the Kickapoo were.
But in fact, there was
no Kickapoo tribe there,
there was something called
the Kickapoo Medicine Show
that Dvorak heard.
And the Kickapoo Medicine Show
was a kind of Pan American music,
it had an African-American
banjo player,
it had people from different tribes,
it was a little bit of a show.
So we really don't
know what he heard.
But it's likely that the
he was taken by this,
although his reactions
to it were ambivalent.
We don't know quite what he thought.
But in any case, there was a
tendency to tie Dvorak to this.
But there's also another thing
in this particular movement
which is redolent of Dvorak.
Dvorak had something of
a reputation of being
in unproblematic happy Czech
and yet, his works are filled
with funerals and funeral marches.
The symphonic poems almost all
have funeral marches in the middle
of the Largo of the New World
Symphony, there's a passage based
on the death of Minnehaha
from the song of Hiawatha.
The cello concerto slow movement
has a funeral interruption
and at the very end of this
movement there's some kind of --
the constant sound which has gone on
and on for five or six minutes stops
and we have this kind
of funeral march.
[ Music ]
So some kind of prairie funeral
being enacted in the course of this.
Now we don't actually know
exactly what to do with pieces
of music right because, you know,
you have this inner longing,
sighing, deep maybe even anguish
and then here's the next movement.
What are you supposed to do with
that, nobody really knows right.
I mean it really is an
astonishing contrast
and this movement is also
another way that Dvorak tried
to make American music and
maybe he can be forgiven
for doing it too obviously.
So again, here's the opening.
[ Music ]
So that passage there.
We're told that Dvorak while
he was writing this sort
of became a little bit obsessed
with the sound of black bird
or with red wings or red wing, you
know, we're not quite sure what.
But we pretty much think it's this.
[ Birds Singing ]
Scarlett [inaudible] and
that Dvorak was trying.
One of the ways that he tried
to make his music American was
to stick an American bird in it
because how can you
say it's not American.
And so we hear this in
various different times.
So here's another one.
[ Music ]
Those are the robin and the bluebird
taken out of a book of bird songs
and stuck right into
the New World Symphony.
[ Music ]
Magpies and blue jays in the
scherzo of the New World Symphony.
So Dvorak decided that in
his scherzo he would stick
in the sounds of this tanager.
And so we have this
sort of full picture.
We have the sadness of the prairie,
we have the energy of coming
into the country and
then we have these sort
of extraordinary bird songs.
The last movement combines
a lot of these things
because we have a kind
of celebratory.
[ Music ]
So again, what are these sounds?
It's these simple sounds.
The kinds of things he
was hearing in black music
that he was sometimes hearing
in Native American music these
little phrases that come together,
but also an extraordinary
sense of lyrical expansiveness.
This is the second theme
in the last movement.
[ Music ]
I mean, you know, you can name
70 film scores that come right
out of this sound, which was
a very influential sound.
But then in the middle
of the movement,
middle of the movements sorry,
exact middle of movement he does
something a little bit unusual.
[ Music ]
So he has kind of reminiscence
of the mood of the slow movement,
the second movement kind of comes
back in a celebratory last movement
to once more sort of suggest
a more reflective mode.
You know, writing a piece
of music is both someone
like Dvorak quite natural,
but also extremely complex.
You're always asking how much
of this do I do before I do some
of that and what's the
effect of that going to be.
And if I want to say
this, how do I say it.
If what I really want to say is
the middle how do I surround it
with various parts.
And in a piece like this just as I
think Mrs. Thurber was experimenting
with what it meant to try
to make American music.
Dvorak was using all these new
ideas combined with his old ones
because the people who don't
like this notion of Dvorak trying
to write American music will always
point out that Dvorak used some
of these same ideas when he was
in the Czech lands, in Bohemia.
That would be like saying
somebody who comes over from Japan
to paint the American West
isn't painting the American West
because they're using a tree.
Well I mean everyone
has a basic technique,
you don't lose your
basic technique simply
because you find new inspirations.
But what Dvorak tried
to do I think was
to quite consciously do what
Mrs. Thurber wanted him to do,
which was again to
create an American music
that was like his Czech music.
I think and this is crude that she
thought he had made Czech music
by taking our basic model, a
German model really of music
and putting Czechisms [phonetic]
in she sort of wanted him to take
out the Czechisms and
put in Americanisms.
And one of the ways he did that
was by not putting in Czechisms.
So there's very little in any
of these American period works
that even by name or deed
or sound suggest polka,
suggest anything other
than American-style.
But there's every evidence
that Dvorak believed in this
and that he believed
that he should try
to show American composers what
it meant to write American music.
Well whether you want to
take the view of some people
and say this led directly
to Gershwin, to Copeland
and to Duke Ellington as my
colleague, Maurice Perez, would say.
Or whether you're a
little bit more skeptical
about how Dvorak's American language
was received, there's no doubt
that he tried to do it and the best
proof of that was a remark he made
in some anger to his student and
amanuensis, Yosef Kovarik she said,
this is -- after he'd written
these pieces he came back.
New World Symphony was premiered,
all kinds of angry cries there's no
such thing as American music
who do you think you are
you don't know anything.
You come from Bohemia you're
going to teach us, go away.
And Dvorak wrote, you know,
they call me an American
composer, you know, but I'm not.
I just tried to show
them what it would be
like to be an American composer,
but I'm not doing that anymore.
And I think by and large
he stopped doing it.
So the fact that he was doing is the
evidence in effect that he stopped.
So these again, are
extraordinary pieces.
Whether you choose to call
this one the American,
Martinu is the Parisian and
Dvorak's earlier one the Habsburg
because it seems to combine all
the styles that you would want
to have together or you
just simply think of them
as extraordinary pieces of music
doesn't really matter much.
But what does matter is the kinds
of intensity and combinations
and contrast that you
get in these pieces.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Anne E. McLean: We have just
a few moments if anybody would
like to ask some questions
for Dr. Beckerman.
>> Michael Beckerman: Yes please.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> Back to Martinu, who were
some of his musical influences,
if any because he doesn't really
sound much like anyone else?
>> Michael Beckerman: Well
I mean that's, you know,
I mean the best thing I've
read about influence not
that I really understand it is that
the reason it's so difficult to talk
about it because the most profound
influences act over a long period
from a great distance, so it's
always tricky to pick them up.
But I think there are several,
I mean I think he was very much
taken with his Dvorak school.
You know, I think in many ways even
though his music sounds different
in terms of the kinds of pieces that
he wrote he chose to follow that.
He studied with Josef Suk,
you know, Dvorak's son-in-law
and I think again, I think he
was influenced by this tradition.
I Again, it's tricky to sort of
make generalizations like this
because they stick
and they ought not to.
But, you know, this was a
tradition of non-virtuosos.
You know, Suk himself even
though he was the leader
of the Bohemian Quartet
was a second violinist.
Martinu was a second violinist.
Dvorak was a violist.
And I think something of
that kind of workman-like,
somewhat modest part of
the tradition comes out
and I think he knew those works.
I think he was interested in
Janacek and I think that comes
out sometimes in the operas.
I was, I mean the person
I spoke to most
about this was a little
trick was Rudolf [inaudible],
who was a student of Janacek's and
a very good friend of Martinu's.
And now Martinu also
was I think very taken
with Albert Roussell
and the French style.
He studied with Roussell and he was,
you know, active and influenced.
There's an extremely strong
Stravinskian influence in a lot
of pieces from that period.
But I think sort of the Martinu
style that he cultivates really
from the 1930's on, I mean again
it draws on Czech folklore,
it draws on Slovak music, it draws
on Czech pastoral traditions.
He richly draws on a lot, but I
don't think there is that kind
of influence I think you're right.
Thanks. Please yes.
>> Was there any overlap
with Smetana's lifetime
and was there any influence with the
[inaudible] in any of Dvorak's work?
>> Michael Beckerman:
Yeah, I think certainly,
I mean Smetana was unavoidable
to Dvorak for many reasons.
One of greatest was that
he played under Dvorak,
I mean Smetana's baton for, you
know, played as second violinist
and Smetana was the conductor of the
orchestra of the provisional theater
and so he obviously learned an
enormous amount from Smetana.
You know and I think
he admired Smetana.
There was a certain level of
rivalry Dvorak Slavonic dances were
extraordinarily successful
and it sort
of illustrates a little bit you
know the Harold Bloom anxiety
of influence because people
often like to tell happy stories,
people often like to tell happy
stories about the relationship
between composers, how they help
each other and Haydn loves Mozart.
But you know Bloom thinks of
this more as mortal combat
and I don't know how mortal it was,
but when Dvorak had
this enormous success
with the Slavonic dances
Smetana kind of shook his finger
and wrote a series
of quite wonderful --
not as popular as Dvorak,
but wonderful pieces called the
Czech dances because he felt
that Dvorak's dances
were not Czech enough.
And he wanted to show him what
it meant to write Czech music
for Smetana was to apply the highest
level intellectual traditions
of modern music, but somehow
referring to local things.
So and I think he felt
Dvorak was too international.
And unfortunately, this became a
very ugly battle not between Dvorak
and Smetana who were mostly gone
by the time the biggest battles
erupted, but it's well-known
that the Smetana's
champion was a kind
of a mustachioed intellectual
villain and his name was [inaudible]
who gained more power than a
musicologist should ever have.
By the time the communists took
power he became the Minister
of Culture.
But long before that he has
basically taught generations
of students to worship Smetana and
[inaudible] and to revile Dvorak
as a kind of bloated, cosmopolitan
who simply whatever good qualities
he might've had he was simply
showing Czech music
the wrong way forward.
So these kinds of things intrude
even now into the literature.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
That was actually composed
almost just before this quartet.
So yeah, I mean the two of
them were dipping into many
if you'll forgive the
terrible pun the same streams.
Yes, anymore questions?
Yes.
>> You commented that Dvorak felt
that American music should
be influenced or maybe led
by African-American music can
you tell us some of the composers
or influencers or musicians
that you might've heard
and been impressed by.
>> Michael Beckerman: Well, you
know, I think his love affair.
Look, I mean the bottom line
is that most of what happened
in the past we don't know right.
So, you know, there's just so many
encounters that he might've had
that we know nothing about.
The ones we know about primarily
are either his encounters
with notated music or his
encounters with specific musicians.
The one who was most influential
in that regard from a lot
of different sources, you know,
you don't necessarily
believe any one source,
but if you have a whole range of
people who don't know each other
who all seem to say the same thing.
So the relationship between
Harry Burley and Dvorak
that one profound way that
that he heard black music.
He knew this Sissieretta Jones,
who was considered the black Patti
singer and she also sang for him.
He probably encountered
more musicians,
but we don't actually
know that much about them.
He had one or two African-American
students
and it's quite possible,
you know, the famous.
Sorry, I've have to
change the key right,
those famous [inaudible]
sounds very much like one
of the plantation songs
written by one of his students.
But he was an ardent
student of these things.
He was given musical notation,
he was given articles and again,
I believe that his first, you
know, interest in this was piqued
when he met Burley and at the
same time read this article
that not only spoke about
the expressive quality
of African-American music, but
gave several musical examples.
And at the same time argued
that these examples should
be the foundation of a music.
Well even if it was a pretext,
even if Dvorak was being paid a lot
of money to make American
music he had to figure out how
to make it and pretty quickly.
And I think it's when he heard these
songs that he felt this has got
to be -- this is my clay out
of which I'm going to make it.
And I don't he ever
really deviated from that.
But you're right, there are not
that many sources other than Burley
and one or two of his students
of musicians that he heard,
although we assume that
he must've heard many.
Thank you.
>> Anne E. McLean:
Wonderful, this is fantastic.
I'm sorry to have to cut you off,
but I know you're going
to love this concert.
Thank you so much Dr. Beckerman.
>> Michael Beckerman: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.